you know keep fighting um you know we've
been in situations you know where we
were down a lot and you know came back
and won and you know early on in you
know my career you know my first couple
years here we was in a situation where
we was up and you know
lost the game so um the message was you
know just continue to fight and go out
in battle and we all know you know the
game is you know never over to you know
zeros on the clock at the end so
that was pretty much the message and
just staying together
uh jaw taylor said after the game you
told the team that you got to be better
what does it say that you won this game
and made the comeback with you dylan and
jaren all sort of not playing at your
best
pretty much you know the same message
same thing i've been saying all season
you know about my teammates
um they deserve you know a lot of more
respect and you know recognition for
what you know they do for us on the
floor uh like you said you know us three
struggle but that's why we got you know
this guy alongside of me and you know
the rest of our teammates to you know be
there to pick us up and you know that's
why you know we're
really the deepest team in the league
and you know we're so good
what impressed you both about your
defense as a team tonight and then also
minnesota
was pretty locked in
throughout the game what can you say
about their job creating turnovers
wreaking havoc and the job you guys did
on that end as well
uh i think just sticking with it
sticking with it and
correcting correcting ourselves holding
ourselves accountable we uh got away
from our defensive game plan um
in that first half uh and that's just
not who we are we were able to to kind
of right that ship uh before the second
half or before halftime there in that
second quarter
then they were able to come come out
they hit us again
in that third quarter and we kind of
were able to correct ourselves again and
it all starts on the defensive end of
the floor and we know that
but yeah it's just holding ourselves
accountable
on that end of the floor because we know
that's that's really what gets us going
uh
tyus it must have felt good to be such a
big part of a comeback on the court that
you
have been playing on since you were a
high schooler um what can you talk about
what that felt like
and uh and john can you just talk about
just
tyus and desmond you know and clark and
just the way they did pick you guys up
tonight uh those three guys you know
were very big time for us um you know ty
is coming in and you know being the
floor general you know controlling the
pace and knocked down some big-time
shots for us and you know during that
stretch where you know dez in bc you
know um was alongside of him and you
know picked us up
a lot of credit goes to those guys i
feel like you know they
pretty much you know uh won this game
for us although you know it's a team
effort but you know they they kept us in
it and you know got us back
uh within you know three at one point
and he had another big three to put us
up one and you know from then on uh we
just continue to you know
fight and was able to come out with a
big-time win
job before the game you said you wanted
to send their fans home
mad
and you know they were booing you all
game every time you touched the ball
how did it feel at the end of the game
you know to get the last laugh
good i'm disrespectful just like they
disrespectful that's why you see i threw
that ball in the air i asked for the
ball
um i know what we're capable of and like
i said
like this morning you know that was our
goal come in and you know win games on
the road and have their fans go home mad
so
you know it'd probably be a lot of
people you know drinking tonight
with that l
i seen a video too
y'all see it later though
sorry i wanted to start with you for to
hold right to hold this team i mean this
was the number one scoring team in the
league back-to-back games you guys hold
them under 100 points what had to change
defensively since the first game uh when
you guys gave up 41 in that first
quarter over the rest of the way um our
physicality our physicality uh
game one they were just too comfortable
they were getting the spots uh
you know i will
um we were just just letting them just
letting them play free and uh you know
they're too talented of a team to uh
to play free and to to be able to get to
their spot so just our physicality and
then our attention to detail like i said
uh tonight we there were times in the
game uh where we got away from that of
you know really being locked in on that
side of the floor
but when we are locked in when we are
physical when we're taking them out of
their sets and uh you know making the
you know making it tough on them uh you
know we're a really good defensive team
yeah just real quick just what it felt
like to do this basically on the court
you grew up on yeah
i mean this is you you know as a kid
from minnesota
you you think of and dream of those
moments play off basketball at the
target center you know that's the nba
team you know you grow up watching um
with you know in the nba arena so you
you dream of those moments um
and so uh yeah i was just just really
ready for it um
you know i prepare work my ass off to be
ready you know in those moments
and then teammates coaches trusted me uh
to deliver in those moments when the
game you know gets gets intense like
that and uh so
it was uh those are moments that i dream
about and uh you know i was just ready
for it
point guard yeah it's his hood
good to see you
hello vc man
real hit man pull your ice out man